Frank Darabont is quoted by go into the
story calm where he discusses quote the
whole industry of we can make you a
screenwriter and he says I have
ambivalent feelings because ultimately
even though there is some benefit to be
gained by those things I stressed the
word some benefit minimal benefit
ultimately you know what it boils down
to you're sitting at your desk all by
yourself for years trying to figure out
your craft and applying the effort
necessary and that's what nobody wants
to hear everybody wants to hear I can
teach you a three-act structure I can
give you a formula and you'll be selling
these screenplays within six months bs
and what's funny about it these guys in
the business of being screenwriting
gurus they don't even write screenplays
I do think there are some benefits of
these classes but I don't think people
should be misled into thinking it's a Bo
and an end-all and that we're going to
walk out a screenwriter everything is
self applied effort in life everything
you don't learn anything easily how
would you respond I could agree with but
the guy more I mean he's absolutely
right for at least 25 years I have been
raining against the fact of that the
normal way that screenwriting is taught
this 3x structure that he mentions is a
bunch of bump it doesn't exist it's
false and it's all about that magic
bullet that I was talking about earlier
that says hey everybody can do this it's
not that hard all you have to know is
that every script has three acts with
two or three plot points it's bull it's
not true and yet an entire industry has
been built on this and it's something
that makes me especially angry because
what it's doing is it's taking advantage
of writers and I love writers I hate to
see them taken advantage of and
especially because of the fact that
almost every writer at least when they
start out before they become a
if they were to get to that level they
have no money they have you know they're
certainly not making any income from
their writing it's a very tough life and
I don't like to see those people taking
advantage of now where I would maybe
disagree with him slightly is in the
sense of that not everybody is doing
what he's talking about you know just as
not all writers are the same not
everybody who teaches the craft of story
is the same and it's I think important
not to tart everybody with the same
brush one of the things that I have done
from the very beginning is be very clear
about what I am doing there with those
students which is I'm not teaching them
the art of writing nobody can teach that
but I think what you can do and what I
try to do is teach all these craft
elements these techniques that I think
are very useful to people and that has
always been the hallmark of all of my
classes which is be practical if it
isn't useful then it's worthless to talk
about the big problem with most of these
writing classes and books is that either
they talk about three-act structure
which is the Emperor's New Clothes
doesn't exist and will not work at the
professional level or you you get talk
about writing concepts that's though so
ethereal has to be useless when you're
actually facing the blank page where I
think comments like that really not
necessarily fail but they don't go far
is these people like Frank Darabont
don't admit or tell you that they have
quite a background of
crafts technique that they know now I
don't know where they learned it a lot
of people they have natural storytelling
ability and then through the the
practice of writing that they have
developed these techniques but those
techniques are real they do exist and
what has always been the purpose of my
class my my main and Adam history master
class is from the very beginning when I
put it together is I wanted to give
writers all the techniques that I
thought were essential that they would
know in order to have a chance to write
a great story and I believe that from
the very beginning I have kept that
promise and I have given that to people
and I think that's why the response to
my classes has been so strong over the
years is that people leave their they
leave with a lot at their fingertips
they have actual practical tools that
will work and can make their story
better and I've got you know stacks of
letters from people including one we
just sent out yesterday from a novelist
very successful novelist written nine
novel novels just sent me a letter
saying thanks for the class that I took
in New York a few months ago because I
just got through the first round of
Sundance and she said thank you thank
you thank you changed my life I mean I
love getting it I'd love to hear that
because it's for me it's all about
making it work because that's really
that that's this writing is so important
for people it is who they are deep down
and so if you can help them turn that
desire that passion into practical
techniques that can get it on the page
it's very fulfilling
you